the libs are absolutely
losing it
over the supreme court's apparent
decision to overrule roe versus wade i'm
not just talking about the crazy hair
color people on tick tock i'm also
talking about the crazy united states
senators senator laia watha had a full
scale emotional breakdown over the
court's apparent willingness to maybe
sort of kind of restrict her ability to
kill little babies
how are you feeling i am angry angry
angry and upset and determined the
united states congress can keep rovers
to sway the
they just need to do it i've never seen
you so angry you seem to be this is what
the republicans have been working toward
this day
for decades they have been out there
plotting
carefully cultivating these supreme
court justices
so they could have a majority on the
bench who would accomplish something
that the majority of americans do not
want 69 of people across this country
across this country red states and blue
states old people and young people want
roe versus wade to maintain
those numbers
we need to know
we have a right
this shrill lunatic is on the verge of
angry tears because the supreme court
might take her tomahawk away you can
look into her eyes and see a kind of
madness this is no mere political issue
you look into our eyes
you're seeing this sense that
quetzalcoatl is going to be deprived of
his human sacrifices that's the kind of
issue we're talking about here okay
because roe versus wade and planned
parenthood v casey and in this case
dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization these are not ordinary
political cases okay and
i would expect more leaks and i would
expect a whole lot more than leaks
because this is about much more than
some esoteric debate about the nature of
the law this for the left is religious
the libs are absolutely
losing it over this
dobbs decision which isn't even official
yet by the way we covered it yesterday
there was this leak from the supreme
court uh probably the the predominant
theory right now is that it was a law
clerk for one of the more leftist
justices and most people seem to think
it would be a justice in sonya
sotomayor's office
again this is just speculation but the
reasoning here is that sonya sotomayor
is by far the furthest left and most
partisan judge and so it would seem
likely that she would hire very far left
very partisan law clerks there are
something like
12 people that this could be
when you look at the number of supreme
court law clerks there are
period and then you look at the number
of supreme court law clerks there are
for the liberal justices it would seem
this was leaked by a liberal justice
then we were talking about maybe a dozen
people that this could be so they'll
they'll
they're investigating it right now the
chief justice john roberts has ordered
an investigation but the lake has
already achieved its purpose which is to
get the left wild angry outside
demonstrating putting a lot of political
pressure on the court and trying to flip
the votes there hasn't been a firm vote
on this yet roe versus wade has not yet
officially been overruled we hope it
will be but we don't yet know and the
lift is already going into overdrive
about it eric swalwell
former future president of the united
states one of the first guys out of the
2020 democrat presidential primaries
eric swalwell who then embarrassed
himself on national television eric
swalwell who was then found to be
bumping uglies with the chinese spy eric
swalwell tweeted out
the republicans won't stop with banning
abortion they want to ban interracial
marriage do you want to save that well
then you should probably vote
what so the first part republicans want
to ban abortion true
republicans want to ban interracial
marriage uh not true not only not true
but not related in any way
to the
it would be it would be like saying
the republicans won't stop with banning
abortion
and
they they like to put pineapple on pizza
too what do you do you support pineapple
on pizza vote for me it's just
completely unrelated and the claim they
make is not true and also it's very
difficult for democrats to make the
claim that the pro-life movement is
racist
democrats always revert to this line of
calling their opponents racist because
it's all they've got when a leftist
calls you a racist you know you've won
the argument and they do it completely
baselessly but they only do it because
to be called a racist is to be called
the worst possible thing you can be in
modern america so they just do it
without any basis but it's especially
preposterous with the issue of abortion
because black babies are
disproportionately the victims of
abortion the pro-life movement
disproportionately is saving black
babies the abortion rate among black
women is five times the abortion rate
among white women
that's not even a number according to a
pro-life research center that's
according to the guttmacher institute
that's according to the pro-abortion
center and they're admitting yes
abortion kills
five times as many black babies as it
kills white babies in new york
more black babies are aborted than born
in new york the most dangerous place for
a black person is in his mother's womb
so the pro-life movement
really doesn't have anything to do with
race
the pro-life movement is simply about
saving babies from being killed race
doesn't play a role in it but if you're
going to insist on making race an issue
here then
the pro-life movement is one of the most
pro-black movements in the entire cup
probably the single most pro-black
movement in the entire country but what
does eric swalwell know nothing he's
just desperate so he's scraping the
bottle of the barrel here that's what
democrats are trying to do and frankly
swalwell was more articulate than joe
biden which is damning with faint praise
but joe biden was asked his thoughts
about this leaked decision and he almost
formed a coherent english sentence
the idea that we're going to make a
judgment
that
is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to
abort a child
based on a decision by the supreme court
i think goes way overboard
and the decision that we're gonna be and
we're deciding and and no one decides
we're gonna have no abortion come on man
come on jack come on here corn pop
that's just too much man
give me an ice cream cone
so it would seem that the point he's
trying to make is that the court should
not overrule roe versus wade and then we
know elsewhere biden has said roe versus
wade is so central so important
to in the words of john fetterman who's
the lieutenant governor of pennsylvania
now democrat candidate for senate
abortion is sacred they actually say
abortion is sacred
just like every demon worshiping tribe
in the history of the world it's sacred
to sacrifice little babies
because biden and the democrats have
taken up this line
they're saying that if the court does
overrule roe and does get rid of the
fictional national right to an abortion
that we need a national law
passed by congress to codify that
abortion protection that license to
abortion into law the the mistake that
joe makes here in his line is he he
admits that abortion kills a baby
because what what the democrats have
been doing in recent years i say
democrats or i say leftist or i say the
pro-abortion movement there is some
distinction between the the three but
not much there used to be much more of a
distinction like back when joe biden was
voting to try to overturn roe versus
wade in the states
you forget that do we all forget that i
guess we do the new york times actually
didn't forget this about three years ago
the the headline when joe biden voted to
let states overturn roe versus way the
year was 1981
there was an amendment that was being
proposed by
senator hatch i guess it was uh the the
amendment would have
over overruled roe versus weight at the
state level and said states can get rid
of roe if they want to because there's
no constitutional right to an abortion
joe biden voted for that amendment so he
voted practically speaking two over rule
row now he's completely changed his
views on this but he hasn't changed his
rhetoric all that much and so even in
that in that clip of biden defending roe
versus wade and saying we shouldn't
overrule it he says we need the right to
abort a child
a child i thought it was a clump of cell
joe i thought it was just just a zygote
or a
blastula or whatever silly scientific
term they used to describe a baby and
joe didn't do that he said no you need
to be able to abort a child
in the words of naomi wolfe the feminist
who i thought gave a very honest
description of the left's view of
abortion
she said now probably 25 years ago she
said we need to admit that the baby is a
baby the baby is alive and women need
the right to kill that baby in all of
its humanity if they want to be the same
as men
ghastly it's a horrific opinion
but at least she's being honest there
at least joe biden was accidentally
being honest there yeah we're aborting a
child
not even just a baby a child a mother
killing her own child what a society in
which mothers kill their own children
will do anything there's no limit to
what they can do
and this is a big change
big change for joe biden who once had i
think sincere opposition to abortion at
the very least it was politically
convenient for him now whatever
sincerity that was and whatever
convenience existed that's totally gone
the guy is full
throatedly in support
of
ritual human sacrifice
did you like that clip cool
ring the bell please subscribe get the
notifications don't miss a single second
of a video
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]